one thing that i always found weird
about the anime youtube community
specifically and this was very much as
an outsider looking in is i mean i was
in the community right like
i made content yeah but i never
participated in anything and i didn't
make the videos that they would
typically consider animating yeah yeah
no other community does this where they
try and like rank who's the best
in their mind with content which i find
really odd like you never see the meme
channels being like
here's the tier list of the best meme
channels you know what i mean
you never get like oh yeah no dolan dark
is better than grand
you know what i mean yeah yeah no one
gives a [ __ ] everyone's just like
everyone's just like i like grande i
like this right it's like
no one does this weird thing but for
some reason in the anime community
they are obsessed with like ranking each
other and seeing who has the best
content
yeah and it's really just noticed it's
only the energy you know
the community does this and it's so
weird it's the gaming community to do
this no no
i've never seen that no one does and
it's weird how like
on the outside looking i was like wow
they really just normalized this amongst
themselves
they really just love stroking each
other's egos and and it's weird because
no other content no other community
really does this where they like
all they do is like compliment each
other they're like damn yeah that was a
good video
it's like that business meme you know
where like yeah it's really business
it's a very good business it's a great
business
business executed it's weird
as someone who didn't do the type of
content the anime content that they
you consider you weren't like officially
recognized yes yes
okay as somebody i'm sure a lot of you
are like know nothing about the anime
community right so i'll break it down
real quick to you how the anime
community works as an outsider and you
can tell me if my understanding is wrong
okay so i made anime content that was
very entertainment based i would take
characters and do
weird stuff with them like prank yeah
right the anime community
has uh uh two types of videos that they
consider
anime content if you see a tier list
likely anything else that is not this
will be linked lower and that's reviews
or analytical videos right
yeah and what i mean by that is
obviously reviews of shows if you review
shows
or episodes or episodes or manga you
know whatever
and analytical videos where you do that
[ __ ] that you did in english class where
you break down why the curtains are blue
you basically write in there yeah yeah
yeah yeah video and
you know why deku uh fists you know in
the appropriate way that he does
right that's how deku mastered his
fisting technique
20 20 minute video red circle that's
right like it's that type of content
where they like or like the logic of uh
harry souza mia i'll have to have a
title like that right it'll be
basically you gotta talk about a
specific show where you talk gotta talk
about anime shows
in general and it's a really strange
obsession where amongst themselves of
all these like small youtubers or like
i'd say between
10 and 100k yeah they are obsessed with
doing these videos and who can do the
best of these videos and ranking
and it's so odd looking from the outside
in it it's just like it's weird
watching them fight over this yeah it's
like what's happening like
this has gone beyond like criticizing
each other's work
to a point of like extremes i think like
it's gotten really strange just
become a giant and they don't really
they don't yeah it's a giant it's a
circle jerk right and they don't
really recognize any other type of
content and i'm okay with that because
the i think what it comes down to most
is that most people who make videos
i'd say most youtubers make it to serve
the audience or to make a content for
the audience
yeah these youtubers in the anime
community make content for each other
yeah and to be like appraised by each
other and you have their content like
you know if if gives me the a plus on my
video it's kids
that's all i ever wanted right yes this
semester exactly
because obviously i want to be validated
by my peers yeah it doesn't right but
that's not the only thing i wanted when
i was starting to make content
for these for these entertures it's the
be-all end-all right that's
i the sense i could be wrong and i'm
sure a lot of them would disagree but
yeah
from the outside looking at it it seems
like i i actually totally agree with you
and i i don't think it's just there's
anime anime
youtube's uh scene i've seen it
specifically or at least like i really
like
the anita community because i remember i
had a very similar experience
when i first started dipping my toes
into the abridging community
now this was this was all the way back
back in the day when bridging was like
the [ __ ]
yeah everyone wanted to be like team
four star and everyone was making their
own
abridged content and everyone had like
that a lot of different
approaches and a lot of them were [ __ ]
right
you can say that though no no but a lot
of them were [ __ ]
right because because a bridge bridging
is hard it's hard i've done a bridging i
can
i can wholeheartedly say it is [ __ ]
hard
but what happened is this community
formed and it was there was like these
forums that popped up
and what happened is that people would
just start start to criticize
each other's work each other's writing
on comedy right and
they're all experts no no no no because
because it was
it did become kind of a circle jerk
where people were where people were
in the end making content to appeal
to each other you know what i mean
people people are just people who are
literally
on these forums reviewing comedy writing
in a bridging and i'm not saying like
that's not not so pathetic not not to
say that comedy can't
there isn't a science behind comedy or
there isn't like a framework that you
can work off of
but what that did it just it just made a
lot of abridging
so [ __ ] stale and so samey yeah
because everyone's doing this trying to
please each other so everyone's trying
to write the same [ __ ] yeah yeah and
then i also feel like what happens is
that when a big channel say of team four
start right yeah if they give positive
praise to someone who's maybe up and
coming
yeah you know maybe they will think oh
well they were nice to me so i'll praise
their writing and then it's like this
giant circle jerk of like
the people who want to be respected and
and the new guys want to be respected
they'll just pass around the compliments
to each other yeah because they're like
this is what we need we need this
respect from each other yeah exactly
and i i saw i see the exact same thing
with with
a lot of smaller annie tubers now where
they they try
they it's they try to make content to
appeal to like each other other
youtubers
which is why whenever you whenever i see
like an annie tuber
that just does something totally
different or just
you can tell right when an annie tuber
makes a video
that is completely like and they don't
watch other anime tubers
because they always make a name for
themselves i remember the first time it
happened was with uh demolition d
like you can tell he had a completely
new style
that no other annie tuba like had before
and i remember like i remember watching
one of his video videos early on and i
remember thinking he's he's going to
[ __ ] blow up
yeah and that's that's exactly what
happened and now he was like
he's he's quit now he's he's like he's
like that urban legend for us any
cheapers yeah right but he's like one of
the most respected content creators
in attitude but like i remember john
super eye patch wolf when he first came
out
i knew he didn't watch any other
anti-tuberculosis oh you can tell
he he [ __ ] blew up as well um i'm
trying to think of this if there's
anyone recently oh
i've got one um i've never talked about
him before
um there's there's this there's this guy
called scam early reviews
[Music]
yeah he's he's like very he's i can tell
he's very new to the scene and
i've seen a lot of opinions about him
online within like the anitchie
community
and a lot of it is very negative just
because
he he the way he phrases it and phrases
phrases things and the way he goes about
his videos is
way more like different and some would
say like brash and harsh maybe arrogant
but from like from myself from like a
content creator perspective
comparing his content to like a lot of a
lot of the things the other anime
cheapers are doing i could say
i could say he definitely has a more
distinct personality
and he definitely stands out even if i
don't agree with all of his content or
or the way he approaches the content
like
i can see that he approaches it he just
feels right yeah
he just he just feels different from the
rest even though he's technically also
doing like analytical content
and he's like grown a lot faster in like
a short period of time and
and i feel like we talked about this you
know making
making content to appease other
youtubers and sometimes you can
definitely tell that
oh yeah i mean i think the reason why uh
someone like
john super eye patch wolf and yourself
are able to get
a plus a million views yeah on a video
talking about
a very specific thing that maybe people
aren't interested in uh
is it because i think you like the
priority is make the video good
yeah don't it's not about trying to
appease someone
or trying to impress another youtuber
because i feel like when you do that
you're just going to iterate on someone
else's idea yeah probably wasn't already
good to begin with yeah but you think
it's good because that's the
in your mind that's that's what you've
been told by the whole community yeah
the golden standard
yeah right when it should be just just
make the good
content just just just make content you
want because i remember
going back to the abridged thing yeah
the the meta game was
try to make something better than team
four star yeah you know it was it was
it was insane it was like i'm going to
make an abridged series and i'm going to
try and make this
more respected in this own circle than
what the big guys are doing right right
you know and i i'm pretty sure like team
four side they didn't really give a [ __ ]
you know what i mean they were they were
they were innovating with dbz bridge and
helsinger bridge and they were just
doing their own stuff
and they were doing stuff because they
thought it was good you know and
i as someone who's been on like youtube
for a very long time you can definitely
feel
when someone is making content with a
completely unique angle and
you get a lot of the same reactions
because a lot of sometimes
sometimes people come up very fast and
people are like what why is why is he
coming up
very fast yeah a lot of the small
youtubers get very bitter about yeah
yeah they're very harsh about it and
you know but then when i can look at the
content or any of us and we can see
exactly why it's succeeded you know we
can break that apart